[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour à tous je suis heureuse
d'être parmi vous partager un certain
nombre donc d'idées sur un sujet qui est
très très important et très fort
aujourd'hui qu'il ya de confiance est
bien quand j'étais très jeune
en fait j'étais très curieuse de
l'infiniment grand et j'étais astronomes
amateurs et un peu plus tard j'étais
très curieuse de l'infiniment petit j'ai
fait de la mécanique quantique un de
l'optique non linéaire en tout cas
j'étais curieuse de notre positionnement
à nous tous dans cette immensité nous
qui sommes que des poussières des toiles
est en fait un peu plus tard je suis
devenu spécialiste du traitement analyse
d'image et recherche d'information à
grande échelle et c'est devenu
uniquement domaine d'activité donc tout
ce qui est traitement d'informations et
évidemment donc toutes les questions
aujourd'hui autour des données et
l'explosion des données et des
algorithmes alors très bien aujourd'hui
nous vivons une époque fantastique
fantastic justement par la disponibilité
des données par l'ingéniosité des
algorithmes et des capacités de calcul
est donc l'humain à le grand privilège
et je dirais le confort d'être assisté
par les algorithmes dans différents
domaines de la vie privée
et de la vie professionnelle par exemple
un gps nous guide donc fait les
optimisations nécessaires avec un
certain nombre de paramètres nos guides
barreaux il feu il faut passer bien
entendu en dehors des questions
d'aménagement de territoire ça c'est un
autre sujet mais aussi nous avons des
services qui nous guide qui nous propose
par exemple quel film il faut regarder
vous avez regardé cette vidéo peut être
que l'autre va vous intéresser
peut-être vous celle ci va vous
intéresser mais aussi peut-être que se
livrent à vous intéresser vos cela
serait bien que vous puissiez l'acheter
donc là c'est aussi à notre type de
service à notre type de plates formes
qui nous est proposé donc ça c'est de la
personnalisation à travers les traces
digitales que on laisse en fait sur
notre parcours dans les différentes
plateformes mais aussi dans les sphères
professionnelles si on est recruteur
donc les algorithmes il ya peu nous
proposer une sélection de cv et nous
proposer cette personne c'est la plus
adéquate pour le poste en question pour
un médecin ou un radiologue finalement
ça aide au diagnostic
en fait il ya des avancées très certaine
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
il y a énormément d'avancé de ce point
de vue là et le service est indéniable
maintenant la c je fais référence à un
film peut-être que certains parmi vous
connaissent c'est x man c'est une sorte
de james bond aurait vu un peu et
rajeuni avec samuel lee jackson qui joue
le rôle de méchant dans ce film est pour
faire une manipulation de masse en fait
là bien sûr c'est de la science fiction
évidemment c'est l'interpellation à
l'extrême de ce qui pourrait se passer
eh bien ils distribuent
et cartes téléphoniques gratuitement
pour tout le monde tout le temps et
c'est ouvert c'est open bar
c'est de la grande générosité bien sûr
tout le monde se rue là dessus et et au
final pour ceux qui connaissent le film
en fait c'est un outil de manipulation
de masse donc cette les modèles
d'affaires les business models qui
utilisent les données personnelles sont
des plus lucratifs et c'est pas par
hasard que les plus grandes
capitalisations boursières aujourd'hui
sans justement ces services gratuits
les moteurs de recherche les réseaux
sociaux les moteurs de recommandation de
biens et de services
je ne mentionne pas les marques
évidemment mais je pense que vous savez
tous de quoi je parle d'accord donc la
valorisation des données personnelles
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
[Musique]
vraiment très très lucratif et c'est ça
qui génère les plus grandes frustrations
quand on dit les grands industriels du
numérique
en fait au final quelque part c'est ceux
qui ont le meilleur business modèle
conçu sur la base des données
personnelles
maintenant dans notre côté donc d'une
part la valorisation est lucrative mais
dans l'autre côté de notre côté ça
permet de tirer des informations
extrêmement importantes sur les
tendances comportementales d'accord les
tendances comportementales et bien c'est
utile dans différents domaines dans le
marketing digital pour cible et faire
des donc cibler des populations pour
pousser des publicités personnalisées
bien sûr mais aussi souvenez vous la
faire cambridge analytica pour faire de
l' influence d'opinion pour des
campagnes électorales
donc là aussi il ya un côté impact sur
la vie démocratique
d'accord ça peut également donc ce ses
informations personnelles décliné des
offres personnalisées en termes
d'assurance que ça soit au niveau de la
santé au niveau de la conduite
en tout cas ça dit satire des
informations de comportement des gens
d'accord donc c'est modèle gratuit
en fait c'est modèle d'affaires basé sur
des services gratuits
exploitant les données personnelles en
fait il faut réfléchir à deux fois
d'accord alors justement comme il ya
cette prolifération
finalement il ya le bon côté et le
mauvais côté et et mon propos ici c'est
ne pas être naïf ne pas sûr vendre les
capacités de liam et ne pas être naïf et
avoir la tête sur les épaules par
rapport à tous ces avancées qui sont
indéniables l'humain qui est par nature
paresseux je dis ça parce que la paresse
est un signe d'intelligence pourrait
avoir une tendance au final à se laisser
guider par des algorithmes qui font les
choix à sa place au final pourquoi
aurais je besoin de réfléchir si je
doute j'aimerais bien avoir une solution
qui m'est proposée par ailleurs et en
interpellant on pourrait se poser la
question est ce que l'humain va garder
son libre arbitre à d'accord donc là
effectivement on peut se poser
réellement la question justement en
interpellant un peu plus dans le temps
si on se laisse aller à être guidé dans
les choix qu'on est amené à être fait
dans la vie personnelle dans la vie
professionnelle
en fait il y a en fait il ya de quoi se
poser des questions bien maintenant on
peut légitimement aussi se poser la
question peut-on faire confiance aux
décisions piloté par la télé notre
artificiel
alors et quand je parle de diète
confiance parce que c'est ça le propos
est bien
l'ia de confiance c'est d'abord une ia
robuste c'est à dire une maîtrise
technologique une répétabilité
d'algorithmes et une robustesse contre
les billets des données et des
algorithmes d'accord c'est pas quelque
chose qui est de laisser c'est un sujet
aujourd'hui hautement pointu au niveau 2
du monde de la recherche
l'iap confiance en plus d'être unie à
robuste s'est uni un responsable ça veut
dire quoi responsable respectent la
réglementation en vigueur respecte les
valeurs de société donc irresponsable et
ya robuste s'est s'allié de confiance
maintenant quand on parle dit un
responsable effectivement on peut se
dire faut-il réglementé etc
on se pose la question de la
réglementation mais en fait la
réglementation existe le con si je
prends par exemple ici le consentement
le consentement c'est en droit depuis
longtemps d'accord donc il existe on n'a
pas toujours besoin de réglementation il
ya déjà
donc on peut se poser la question est ce
que ce consentement est toujours
respectée parce que c'est un droit mais
est ce qu'il est toujours respectée et
dans ce sens en fait je voudrais vous
parler d'une étude concrète qui a été
menée par la cnil à une équipe de
recherche utilisant des algorithmes de
contrôle d'information c'est à dire des
informations entrantes des informations
sortante et des appels système sur des
applications que tout le monde peut
télécharger sur son smartphone la
préservation des données personnelles là
aussi ses protégés largement par
diverses lois et bien l'application vous
pose la question est-ce que
vous voulez partager votre position gps
cochet ici vous ne voulez pas partager
votre position gps que j'ai ici
et bien cette étude a révélé que quelle
que soit la réponse quel que soit votre
choix
en fait votre position gps est prise en
compte
donc quelque part la confiance dans les
services qui nous sont proposés c'est
bien moi je dirais que la preuve de la
confiance c'est encore mieux
d'accord la preuve que le consentement
est respectée c'est encore mieux
alors mon propos c'est que les
algorithmes font partie de la clé de la
réponse d'accord les algorithmes fed a
observé le comportement d'autres
algorithmes les algorithmes sont des
outils de transparence de l'intelligence
artificielle l'humain seul ne peut pas
vérifier dans le cas que je viens de
vous donner
si oui on en sans consentement est
respectée des algorithmes peuvent le
faire et encore une fois quand on parle
d'algorithmes c'est toujours les humains
qui les encoder parce que c'est pas l'ia
n'est pas quelque chose d'abstrait n'est
pas il faut pas un personnifié lia l'ia
ce sont des opinions encapsulé donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle des
algorithmes peuvent aussi contre les
pour nous donc la véracité de ce qui est
fait bien donc lié de confiance c'est
aussi une question interdisciplinaire
c'est vraiment essentiel de le
comprendre et de vraiment de l'assimiler
bien entendu le savoir faire de base et
de coeur c'est les sciences
mathématiques et les sciences
informatiques évidemment mais pas que il
ya les sciences humaines et sociales les
sciences sociales les sens juridique les
sciences économiques
c'est tout un savoir faire qui est
nécessaire
donc une interdisciplinarité réelle et
forte
dès la conception il ne s'agit pas de
faire les choses en séquences on perd
beaucoup de temps et on perd beaucoup
d'efficacité c'est de la co conception
entre les disciplines qui est nécessaire
c'est un peu comme la fable des des
moines aveugle donc qui souhaite
reconnaître
donc cet animal qui est très grand et en
fait une personne seule ne peut pas en
fait identifier ce que c'est chacun a sa
propre vérité c'est à dire il y en a un
qui va toucher le pied il va dire là
c'est un tronc d'arbre
celui qui va toucher l'oreille il va
dire une ça ça doit être un éventail
celui qui va toucher la trempe il va
dire ça c'est en serpent donc en fait
c'est pas faux chacun 200 de là où il
est c'est pas faux il a sa vérité mais
sa vérité locale mais ça ne permet pas
d'accéder à la big picture je dirais a
justement à ce qui est l'objet mais la
conjugaison de ces savoirs et de ses
vérités partielles au final permettent
de reconstruire de manière holistique
l'entité en question donc c'est vraiment
ça l'importance de l'interdisciplinarité
il faut jamais avoir un seul spectre
pour résoudre des problèmes aussi
complexes que l'intelligence
artificielle
alors c'est aussi une affaire de tous
donc la ferrandaise il aime mais aussi
de tous les acteurs quand j tous les
acteurs aussi ça démarre au niveau
individuel citoyens consommateurs
gardez votre libre vraiment votre
capacité de décision de questionnement
ne vous enfermez pas dans ce qui vous
est uniquement proposé parce que sachez
que malgré tout l'efficacité qui peut
exister les algorithmes pourrait en
fermer les uns et les autres dans
certains choix qui manque de diversité
qui manque de panache
d'accord donc c'est essentiel de garder
son libre arbitre de ne pas diffuser
quand c'est pas nécessaire ses données
personnelles parce que sachez que c'est
c'est ce que je disais au début le
profilage
il y est toutes les données personnelles
d'accord mais aussi c'est le rôle des
chercheurs et des industriels donc ceux
qui mettent sur pied de nouveaux
algorithmes qui travaille sur la
robustesse mais aussi qui travaille sur
une nouvelle génération delgo rythme qui
sont par construction éthique et
respectant les valeurs de société
également quand on parle de sociétés
quelles valeurs de société en veut il ne
s'agit pas de définir des valeurs dans
un pays et pas dans l'autre
aujourd'hui la commission européenne
donc l'union européenne a constitué un
groupe d'experts de haut niveau sur l'ia
justement pour définir des valeurs
communes mais aussi faire des
recommandations à la fois de politique
générale mais aussi d'investissements en
recherche développement d'accor le lot c
d e à constituer un groupe d'experts
également gels eu l'honneur et le
privilège de participer aux deux pour
rassembler justement ces points de vue
pour atterrir sur des valeurs réellement
communes et pas chacun qui définit sans
référentiel sans que ça se parle
l'idée c'est vraiment avoir un modèle de
ce site et qu'on partage mais aussi les
politiques et les régulateurs les choses
c'est le rôle de aussi de l'état quand
je dis et a pas qu'en france c'est aussi
le rôle des états européens
c'est pour ça qu'on réfléchisse à un
niveau beaucoup plus globale ça ne va
pas se faire tout seul
d'accord donc un grand pas pour
l'humanité pour l'ia de confiance c'est
aussi la traçabilité des services et des
algorithmes et donc ce c'est vraiment le
genre de d'idées que nous sommes en
train de pousser et en tout cas ce que
je disais c
une affaire de tous et chacun là où il
est il a un rôle à jouer pour que
justement
donc on puisse diffuser une haie et
déployer développer une ia au service de
l'humain et de la société
merci
[Applaudissements]